Hello, my name is Monica Diaz, and I'm going to have a conversation with Ash
Faith for Visible Lives, an oral history project at the New
York Public Library. Today is January 13th, 2015,
and this is being recorded at the New York public office,
public library office near midtown Manhattan. And
can you start by telling us a little bit about yourself?
Hi, guys. My name is Ash Faith
and, boy, where do I begin? Um.
I have a traumatic brain injury.
I entered a two-month
and woke up randomly thinking I was into
work when I was really in a back brace in a hospital bed
and I ... after waking ... that was in
August 2010. The
accident was in June 2010, so two-month coma....
I mean, wake up afterwards and I then stayed in
both a hospital and a rehabilitation facility for the
duration of the year. And I actually had to
bounce from the facility that
I was in because medical cruelty.
So. [laughs.]
my, um, my school of hard
knocks, per se, was not only the medical cruelty but
also leaving an institution
early and, going with the punches
in New York City in whatever way it came.
That must have been difficult. How ...
Tell me a little bit more about your time in the rehab facility
and how ?inaudible?
Well, I mean. Um, even though I woke up in the
hospital, it was in rehabilitation unit, so....
My accident. Was on June, June
sixth, 2010. Three weeks after graduating college.
It was just one of those situations where I was at the wrong place at
the wrong time, and I
ended up being in the same car as a drunk driver, and
he ended up crashing into a pole on a
major highway, and because I didn't have my
seatbelt on, being in the back seat, I ended up flying through the
window into the woods. My skull and
brain sheared against each other, and I flew
so far they couldn't find me for a minute.
But they found me, and I was in a nasty
coma.
For those two months, obviously my family and friends were all
alerted, and thankfully I had just
the right kind of support that I needed during that
time.
When I woke up on August fifth, 2010, it
was...it was just like... I was so confused. For
like the first week. Between my past memories before the
accident, colliding with the present
circumstances.
I was just confused most of the time, and like, thankfully
it's in my nature to just go with the flow. So
I adapted, I adopted that mentality and
while there was a lot of ups and downs, um, I'm thankful to have
made it this far.
Five years later.  "Yeah. It's been five years."
Other than your family, like, where else did you get that support system
system?
Family and friends, and I work with some
doctors, um. You know, doctors, some...
Each doctor has, like, a way of showing their
care and ...
was...
I'm very thankful that I've worked with the right types of doctors 'cause even
though the care varied and, and like,
dedication and, like, emotions and all that
and did what I needed to do, and then... aside from a little ?mental? cruelty.
that's... That wasn't even from doctors. That was from lame nurses who
just didn't know how to, like, treat their patients, but, like, it
was, I mean, I don't want to get graphic but, I mean,
you're like an infant again, so I was again potty-trained
and I don't have nurses
like, literally make fun of me for being in my early
twenties, brain-damaged, and, like, and going through
this process that was indeed painful in retrospect.
Emotionally. "Emotionally, yeah."
Well, the shit hit the fan when a
nurse ended up pushing my wheelchair against the wall.
So I proceded to say fuck you to her. And she said, Fuck me?
No, fuck you. And she gyrated her ass in my face like a cheap porn star.
Oh, my goodness.
"Yeah." "I'm sorry." "It's, it is what it is."
Like, being able to cope and move on, you know,
and I can just, like, remember it, I mean, like, that was distasteful
but like....
Were any other of your peers or any other patients also
experiencing  some of those, some of that harassment? "Actually"
Well I feel like, I'm the membership coordinator of the Brain
Injury Association in New York City, so the past couple of years has
allowed me to connect with others that I have the same brain
injury. The only thing with brain injuries is that it affects
everyone that has it individually. So it's, like, it's a very
unique, like, for example, my brain injury wouldn't be the same as your brain
injury, God forbid. Or like another person with a brain injury. We
all show signs of it differently.
And a lot of it has to do with social environments,
in the home environments, like.... So I
ended up connecting with,
with a gay male that also has a brain injury.
He's, like, ten to twenty years older than me
and he actually ended up in that same hospital and he
was just like
You survived place too? I'm like, yeah, dude, I'm like, and we're just
comparing our timetables and, like, it was like right when I left,
he entered, like, a few months later. So it was just, it was just crazy.
But he also had, like, a deep disdain for his
experiences there. The only perks of that place was the therapies.
Because they have good doctors.
Yeah. The nurses, I hope they get their act together.
And, and so you mentioned that the therapies, you really liked those, right?
Sorry, are you still doing some of that? "Yeah, I took, I took a
hiatus. I, I don't know. Well
gosh, that's kind of a lengthy story. Well, when I got
out of the nursing home I was
only able to get my rehabilitation therapies
arranged, like, within a couple of months, and then there
was, well, dealing to doctors was pretty cool
and, like, Russ was right. I went and go again
as of today but anyway like I ended
up having to deal with not institutional violence through them
but through like Access-A-Ride, different ambulette services...
I mean, one of them was named Dedicated and they were the
opposite of that. And.
Access-A-Ride just wouldn't show up, like, I mean, they just don't, they're very
notorious for that. Like, yeah, it's an amazing resource for New York City to
have, especially if you have a disability,
but show up, you know. "You're counting on them." Because we've got no other
choice but to count on them and when they just, like,
won't show up on time to take you to your
therapies, they'll run that pace where it isn't them,
it's you. And one of
the therapies that I had back
then that I'm seeing, that I started again today actually,
occupational therapy. Well it was amazing
and beneficial. It got me that, like, three strikes, you're
out type of deal because I would, like, not show up on time and
it would be beyond my control, especially then. I was like, I
would be in my lobby, waiting for like forty-five minutes to an hour just to
go to therapy and that, I mean, even though patience is a therapy in
itself, that wasn't part of the agenda.
Yeah.
It sounds like, you know, from your experience you've kind of become an advocate for
this community, people who suffer from these type of injuries. How, how have
you brought that into your role as a coordinator?
Well. "Tell me a little bit more about your..." Well, the coordinator part
part is super fresh.
Like, I was a sociology
major and... "Me, too." Oh
And so I have a lot of experience with, like, social activism
and advocacy and all that.
And I kind of just, like, use this notion of lived
experience as my anchor to
recover and regenerate from this
injury and of course it had multiple
phases that I went through.
I'm very grateful to be in a phase where I can, like, connect
with the city, with the state, with the world if I can.
But, you know, if I want to. And a lot of
people would see that drive in me, but they just, like, I
mean, well they would be supportive. They would also be,
like, concerned that I would, like, relapse
in ways, in ways that I used to live my life before my
accident. I was just very daring. I wasn't, like,
a drug addict, thankfully, I never made it to that extreme
but I sort of see it with a lot of, with a lot of addicts, with a lot of
people from different sides in the world.
And while there's no regrets with that, the lifestyle that I led
was a little bit daring, if not, like, self-
exploitive. I would just, I would just be on, like,
thin ice with some of my actions. But just like I lived and learned
through them, I also chose to
live and learn through my experiences in the city
afterward.
So you wake up on August 5th, you think you're late for work, right?
Uh-huh.
But, you know, you... There's something else that happened right
after that, right? You, you were living this daring life. What, what did you, what were
some of the biggest lessons you learned, you know, in your journey to recovery?
.
Trust. I mean, I used to
think that... I just used to have a sense of righteous resistance
where I would be, like, very in your face, like, get
out of my way, please and thank you type of
guy and
I just don't think that I applied a sense
of wisdom to my actions.
So I absorbed a lot of people's actions
as a way to navigate my own, and there
was just inevitable consequences that came along with that.
My accident and my disability
were climactic, in the sense where
not only was, did I, was I able to, like,
down or sit down and, like, have to confront my demons, like,
no escape. There was also my loved ones
are different,  different friends and family that were just, like,
having to not only confront
my demons as, like, a secondary presence but
also, like, but also confront their own.
And, you know, it was just like a very two-way
inter-crossing interdependent type of
scenario that was occurring.
What was the hardest thing about the recovery?
I mean, aside, it was... The hardest thing was, is
was feeling abandoned or neglected. Even though I had
the right kind of support when I was in the hospital, coming out, coming
back into the city...
Everyone that supported me in the hospital just made a cameo appearance, you know, it
was like, and, like, no shame in that, like, you know, I'm
twenty-eight, and I was twenty-, I wasn't even twenty-five when this started
happening so even though I had, like, an unyielding
support, there was just this,
like, inevitable independence that, like,
paved a path for everyone, including myself,
that I had to recognize, and you know
before my accident, I was an escapist, for sure, and
I would, I would escape into the company of
others. But with this
disability, even though I had the support from others,
the only love that I had to encounter in the end was love for
myself and supporting myself in my
drive to, to get to where I am. "That's beautiful."
Thanks.
And so, you know, I want to actually take it back a little
bit. I don't think I asked you about your experience growing
up.
You mentioned you've been here in New York but what brought you
here. Tell me a little bit about growing up.
I, I lived a pretty sheltered yet
awesome lifestyle. You know my parents did their
best raising me. No complaints. There was
always, like, literal... I was born with
hereditary sensory motor neuropathy
but... It's also known as Charcot Marie Tooth.
And, but there was no definition or diagnosis.
for it when I was growing up. Between the ages of, like,
yeah, I think, five, after, like, five
and then eleven and then
sixteen.
I had strokes, where I would just be chillin',
like, you know, minding my business with family or friends and then, like,
half my face would become paralyzed. And no one would know what to do and,
like, when I lived in the city and, I was eleven when it happened.
You were here in New York.  "I was in New York at the time and it happened again when I was in the suburbs at, like,
sixteen or seventeen, but it happened when I was, yeah, and like
sixth grade, and it was so scary. So then, you know,
my parents took me to get looked at, but doctors only...
They had diagnosed me with, like, a symptom
of the Hereditary,
of the neuropathy, and the symptom is hypotonia, which is
decreased muscle tone. So it would be like, Oh, that
makes sense why he's super skinny and has, like, hyper-flexible
wrists and is just as clumsy as Steve Uriel.
Like, like that was...
But, but hypotonia was a symptom of, like, a bigger
thing and that bigger thing wasn't diagnosed until
I was twenty-three, six
months before my accident. I was, I went to school at SUNY
Purchase in Westchester but I had, I
would, like, work at a denim boutique on the weekends in SoHo,
and it was a cool lifestyle to lead at the time.
However that sense of, like, always being on the go
affected my coordination and my, even my, like,
motion.
And so I went to get checked up, and I was,  I have this thing
called hypotonia. You ever hear of it, Doc? And he was just, like,
That's not a diagnosis.
He was, like, Yeah, well, that's like a symptom of a
diagnosis. It's not what you may or
may not have.
So he ended up, like, doing tests on me.
And he came up with Charcot Marie Tooth, which has been renamed as Hereditary
Sensory Motor Neuropathy, which makes much sense when you say it... "All this time"
When you say it like that. And I'm, like, Wow. Wow. And, like,
then there was the riddle of, like, oh, which parent can it come from? But, like,
neither of my parents showed signs of it. And if they did, it
was, like, super subtle, like, it was, like, I'm just, like,
diving, like, head straight into it, because this T.B.I.
is definitely an icing to the cake.
How, how have they, I mean, how have you dealt
with both of these things now? "Oh, I was bummed from that. I was super-bummed.
I mean, aside from, aside from being a misfit before my
accident, you know, I just, even though I was a social butterfly,
like, I was also a hopeless romantic, so, you know,
just being, like, an extroverted gay male.
since I was fifteen. And having to, like, not
only deal with, like, the cues of social rejection but also like, a
body, that type of rejection.
It was so interesting because I didn't have an answer for it and I just
have like likeminded friends who
could appreciate me for me
and vice versa.
But it was always that, like, any time, like, you would see me run or you would see me
or just like, you know, coordinate myself, you would be, like, You're so cute and flimsy.
And I'd be, like, Thanks. ?Friends? of showing Steve Urkel on
Friday nights when I was a kid.
That was my, like, immediate way, to, like, you know,
recognize it. But, when I was a, you know, not
this official diagnosis six months before my
accident, while studying S&M for my thesis,
senior thesis, that I was just, like...
But... It was...
I feel like, when I came
out, let's see, I was back home in, like, January
2011. So six months later, and then
.
by the summertime, even though I had a
routine going, like, my outpatient therapies, even ??
services.
Dealing with, like, ambulette cruelty
was like a wake-up call that the city ain't this, like,
you know, lovey-dovey place, and, like, being a native, I knew
that at the heart, but, like,
Can't you even cut a dude with a cane or a walker some slack. One time,
Oh my gosh. I'll never forget this. Sorry to be on a tangent, but, like,
it happened, I think within 2011, like the end of 2011, beginning of 2012
I ditched the ambulette services and had the courage to
start navigating the subways on my own. "Ah" Yeah, I just, like, didn't call.
I was, like, you know, I not gonna call them, I'm not even gonna call my mom. I'll just
do this, so I took my cane and I just ended
up, you know, going out. I was just mindful how I went down the steps
but it was fun. It was, like, easier than I thought. And one
time, I was on 34th Street and Herald Square
and I was in rush hour and, it was, you know, I was crossing
the street and this stranger just, like, saw me and she helped
me cross the street so I could dodge the cars. She was, like, some people are
assholes. And I'm, like, Yeah, thanks for the help.  So, you know,
having that hope was awesome. And then, no joke, like twenty minutes later I'm
on the subway, and this guy,
like, you know, in a really, like, tight blue vest is just, like
walking up the stairs in the rush-hour crowd, and I'm going down the stairs
and he just pushed me to the side, and I didn't fall down the
stairs, thank God, but he was like, he was in, like, such rapid
mode that he just, like, pushed me out of the way.
And like, I was, like, saved ?by those scenes.?  It was like crowd-
surfing. "Crowd-surfing." Yeah,
and, thankfully, you know, there was, like,
you know, I mean, caring
New Yorkers that were helping me out, but I was just, like, What just happened?
That was your first... "It was my first time." ...time?
My first... It wasn't the first actual time, but it was, like, the first day
Of
being underground and I was, like, Whoa. "Well, I've been
living in New York for about a year now, and I've definitely encountered both the
nastier side of people and just really
awesome people who will go out of their way, out of their way to help
or just even smile. There's just... "Totally. Totally."
So tell me about you, pre and post
the injury. How has it changed your experience as a
New Yorker? What do you think? How has the city kind of, other than those
stories, how has it embraced or helped you?
I think I always had it in my nature
to, I just always had a drive, you know, even when I
lived in the suburbs and I got my license, I'd be driving
places like that. People'd be like, Why do you have to
you know. "You're exploring." Yeah, exactly, so that's in my nature. To explore
and, in
New York City, like, the ways that I would explore before the
accident compared to after the accident are different.
I, I'm a meditation teacher now,
but I have undergone a meditative
lifestyle for sure after my accident, that
I flirted with before but, you know, I would
be, like, some dessert to, like, you
know, the adventure cake
and New York... I feel like New York is different in the sense
that, like, a
lot of people, it's like, a lot of people that aren't
from New York are now living in New York, and, like, there's just this
cohabitation happening. And there's so many social
frontiers, like gentrification and all that.
My experience coincides more
with, like, institutional presence. So it's like my
presence as a disabled person within
different institutions. The first institution
that I found and thankfully grew with,
with their help, was, it's called the Anti-Violence Project
and they're, like, a few blocks away from here.
And that, being with them
enabled me to exercise my voice
beyond somebody going to speech therapy for a traumatic brain injury, even though
that was amazing too. Like,
they had trained me in hotline counseling,
public speaking, and
they also helped me unravel certain instances
of violence that I was exposed to before on my accident that I didn't
necessarily have much of a voice to articulate and if I did, it was more
of a fuck you, get out of my way type of deal, but, you know, I was able to,
like, process all these, all this
variety of emotion that
was anchored by violence, to say the least.
What kind of violence? "Well, I mean, my car
accident, the car accident that I was in had traces
of
intimate partner violence. I was in a, I wasn't
really involved, like hardcore, with the person but it was
just the person was like an anchor
towards my desire for other men. We've known each other since I was
fourteen so between the history with that
and our experiences together and, like, the history of past experiences
that are unrelated to him, the fact that it
all culminated to getting thrown out
a window, you know, and I having my head and
brain flirt with each other for
a few minutes was scary. I'm like, whoa,
and you know, surviving the coma. I had a very vivid near-death
experience that I talk about in the books that I'm
writing. And...
Tell me about that incident, or are you not ready to talk about it? "No, I totally could.
About the near-death experience?" The near-death experience...yeah.
Yeah yeah. Or tell us about even your books.
Well, for starters, for my near-death experience,
I thought heaven was a VIP lounge and I was getting denied.
Yeah, I was, I thought I was getting rejected from a club.
?Resented some of the chilling glow,? like all the other souls that I was
witnessing and my
mental landscape and it was just a very
real, surreal experience to say the least.
I'm currently writing...
I started writing my four books when I was in the hospital
actually. My process in writing these books first and foremost
is to hand write them in multiple note-
books, using the stream of
consciousness method and three of the
books--they're called ?Laddie? Stardust,  Freeze,
and Jay Gaze ?Gays? And Laddie
Stardust explores this notion of daring
innocence.
So it's, it just, it talks about
my life, like how I grew up in this
safe world and how I was just like
hungry to be unbound by that type of
safety and as a result experience what I did.
And Freeze is kind of like an ode to my trauma.
Because even though I have this traumatic brain
injury that I survived, a year and a half before
my accident, I was assaulted and I got P.T.S.D.
.
So, you know, trauma was no
stranger to me when I was, received this diagnosis. So
Freeze is, explores this notion of, like,
being. The character is a renegade intellectual
and just absorbs all this knowledge with his lived experience
and process it, processes it
through a traumatic bias, which is
ironically to freeze or to fight or flight.
And Jay Gaze it is a sci-fi novel about
blossoming in a post-modern society.
I'm writing these down. "Cool. Thanks." When are, when is the
release date? "I'm aiming, I'm aiming for Laddie to be
released sometime this year." Great. "I'm gonna get working hardcore on it."
Great, great.
So you also you mentioned your work as a
meditation teacher, right?. How... Are you still, do you still
practice that or
Totally, totally. "Tell me a little bit more about that." Wow, well, OK. I found
meditation three years before my accident. I was
getting stoned with some good friends and practicing kundalini yoga.
And I was a little ?fucked? I won't lie.
It wasn't genuine meditation. It wasn't a practice per se, you know.
And so I experienced that, and it
it ended, like, you know
cycle of life style. And then my
senior year of college,
I was, I had survived my P.T.S.D. incident,
so I started seeing a therapist and he introduced me to mindfulness. And
he would kind of incorporate that in our sessions.
Plus, a couple of sociology teachers were getting big on it too,
so they would use it in their classes. So yeah.
Senior year was all about, like, studying S&M and
discovering mindfulness and, like, and then my accident happened
three years, three weeks later and I remember waking up from my
coma like the first week, and kinda like absorbing the basic
info of what had happened. And I'm like, All right. This
is No time like the present. I'm gonna start exercise my
mindfulness and I got mindful all right all throughout
my hospital stay. And then the more distracted I became,
whether it was through, like, you know, movies or, you
know,
I would just go off to la-la land sometimes.
That is what it is. My meditation practice
strengthened a little bit beyond
mindfulness like a year later
when I followed the lead for this flier that said
Meditation and showed a shiny
brown, bald man in the field and I'm like, oh, this guy looks cool.
I want to see what this is about. And it was at a
elementary school a couple of blocks away from where one of my
best friends used to live in the Village, and I was thinking, Aw,
this has, like, a home, sweet home type of scenario.
And I ended up learning about this man
who was a guru named Sri Chinmoy.
He was, like, super big in the Seventies and Eighties and
Nineties.
And even though he had passed away, and I was seven
I believe his disciples just, like, continued
to spread his message were allied. So this is one of those cases
where the disciples were showing documentaries of him
and they had this new art therapy that I have,
like, a deep respect for, so I'm like, oh, you know, between the art therapy...
Next thing you know, I get invited to their headquarters and
I start meditating with them. And that was some. So towards the end
they were like, OK you can't, you have
to become a disciple
in order to continue to meditate with us. So I was...
Because to be a disciple, you have to wear all white and claim celibacy, which I
wasn't ready to do at twenty-five, so
I ended up going to this coffee house down the street. And there's a
flier that said, Learn to Meditate. The Interdependence Project.
And coincidentally, a good buddy of mine that I went to
college with,
like, that night had posted something
about The Interdependence Project
so, the next
class was, like, a few days later
and I ended up making it. And I had to go up, like,
this,
this
super narrow flight of stairs that I can only describe
if you see it and, like, I just have
this, like, mountain of stairs ahead of me, and I'm like, Alright, no time
like the present, and took my cane, made it up
there and... "Very symbolic, almost." Yeah, totally, and
And I was able to continue my meditation
practice through them. This was in the summer of 2012 and
by 2013 I had entered their immersion
meditation teacher training program.
That was just a life-changing experience, and then all through
2014, with their help and with the help of a good friend
that had just opened up a yoga studio downtown I was able to
get some meditation classes rolling.
And then I, the president of the
Brain Injury Association of New York City ended up inviting
me to teach meditation to the
members for a couple of events.
And that
warmed me up to them, and it got me further involved with the
association. It strengthened
It strengthened my knowledge and
meditation practice with The Interdependence Project as well as
Dharma Punx, who's another meditation group that
meets there on alternate days and
now I'm still chillin' there. I'm, like,
assisting their Monday night Buddha psychology classes and
lovin' it. "Great."
So you're, you're quite an achiever.
How,
how have you used this experience to
maybe
influence but provide me, provide some advice not just to your younger
brother. You mentioned you have a sibling. "Yeah." I don't know if you have... "I have three younger brothers. Yeah."
So how have you used this experience to maybe share some advice
with other people or what, how have you,
kind of...
"I mean." ...helped others through their, through their path?
I, that's funny, I'm, like, going through that with
I'm going
I am trying to form, oh,
trying to form a way to do that in my head currently. "OK."
I feel like not bowing down is my
instant advice.
It's also the advice that has gotten me by all this time.
I, I'm just not the type to bow down, and the best
advice that I can give anyone is to do that whenever they feel
limited or confined by
either their environment or by what others could say to
them.
?warrants no? boundaries because, you know, you can
bow down, boundless, you can not bow down
boundlessly all you want but creating a sense
of boundary is so important, for recovery, for
communicating.
And I feel like you learn that through lived experience.
And
as for a prime intention, the thing I always say to people is
Ignite the light. "Ignite the light. I like that." Thanks.
So aside from meditation
or your work with
the Brain Injury Association, what else do you do in your free time?
I art model and I,
that was something I did before my accident, and
I think the way you realize that was something I could do after my
accident at the Art Students League of New York,
and I'm, I'm a pretty creative person,
so I like that this job, like, enables me to
be creative, whether it's through photography, whether it's by giving me
the time to exercise poetry.
It's, it's just boundless. I like that.
The job with...? "With the Art Students League. Yes." Yes. "And
also with, it compliments my meditation practice
and meditation teaching. ?These? also
meditate and model at the same time. Though a lot
people don't realize that because I just do what I have to do to
strike a pose
at work and it's cool, that.
in
What are the next steps? What's your five- or ten-year plan?
(laughing)
My, my four books out there, definitely within five
years. My
book that I'm working on that I didn't mention before, it's called In Dust
and it talks about,
it talks about... It's like a social commentary
on post-modern society and how we can
thrive with it or just stay under the
radar, whichever way we choose.
It's definitely in construction, but...
I'm hoping to grow as a
model,
as well from art modeling to photography. I used to do photography
when I was in college. Like, I used to pose for
photographers.
That was fun. It's like a different type of,
it's a different kind of fun. It's just, like,
Not as still, per se, and
just explore the world one step at a time.
You mentioned you really like to, you've always had that in you.
Yeah, I mean, I want to be able to travel
and I want to... I don't want
to feel so bound by the work that I give myself. You know, I want to just
like, enjoy the world and interact with all
these different types of people and connect them any which way I can.
I don't even meditation to do that. I'm all about the
interpersonal thriving. "Where would you want to go?"
Oh. I can't really go back. I
visit my motherland of Peru.
Ah. Very nice.
Have you, have you been recently or what was the last...? "I haven't been to Peru
in fifteen years." Wow. "Yeah, so I would love to
go back and just explore.
Explore Spain. "What about Mexico?"
.
It's so funny. I was just, I was just talking to an art model about
just talking to an art model who's from Mexico and she's like, You gotta
see, go to the beaches there.
Yeah, I'm into that. And I would just love to explore Mexico too.
And Colombia and, yeah, I love that.
I went to Peru last year and I,
I'm sure you'll be just as impressed as I was. "Oh, nice." There's just so many
cultures within, and just landscapes
within. So. "It's a beautiful place."
Yeah.
So your, your five/ten year plan kind of revolves around
your books. You want to travel. "I want to make a movie." Oh.
Stardust to be made made into a movie or a TV show.
As an idea that can complement it. How's that? I would just be to
have been on the screen.
Stephen King style. I grew up loving Stephen King. "Really." Yeah, like
when I was, like, in third grade, I was, like Firestarter.
I want to be cool like that
and, yeah, so, I mean,
he's a big role model.
To me. "Actually I had a question. Why
did you choose sociology as...?
Let's stay with sociology before I forget.
What made you choose sociology? "Well, I went to community
college first and
associates in humanities and social science. I was, like, pretty broad and I
had a knack for psycholo. You know, I was really into, like,
me helping my friends and family through their, like, struggles and
whatnot. And then, I wanted to
pursue creative writing.
But we say I didn't really know how to articulate that,
that.
And see, the college advisors at the time, I just thought that I'd
major and a philosophy minor.
Oh, but philosophy, you can, like, you know, name some lines of others. Whatever.
Well, first semester's at this new school
were smack in the face with that and I ended up
taking, like,
a class by
one of the, like, leading professors of that department, and even though
she hadn't met with me and she was like, I don't think
you're meant to be a lit major. I think you should be a sociology
major. And I'm like, Huh? And, like, I didn't even
consider or contemplate sociology and then I,
one of my,
one of my good friends was dating this guy at the time,
who was a sociology major, and we were just talking, and I'm like,
Whoa.
I think, you know, being so into the lived
experience, the way that I was then and am now, I just thought
it was, like, the right path for me to take, and I'm glad that I took it.
It's really cool.
You also mentioned you're a hopeless romantic. "Not so much
anymore." Not so much? That's my next question. "Oh, go for it."
You, you mentioned this relationship or this
kind of. "It wasn't a relationship. It was just..." OK. "a bad fling."
A bad friend.
So how do you, how do you kind of, how do you see
relationships now?
Well, I mean. "Both romantic and just friendship?"  Well, friendship-wise, I'm more
selective. More selective and less defensive.
Though
there are some habits and quirks that I have to,
that I kind of still have to work through but I'm not even sweating it, in the
friendship department. I
think it's just part of the growing up process to figure people out in that way.
I'm always meeting new people, and I love ones that I have in my life,
whether I see them once every few years
or more frequently.
I'm twenty-eight years old and got into first
relationship.
So that was a perk. It's pretty fresh. It started in November
and so far, so good.
And I'm glad to explore that. "I'm happy for you." Thank you.
So it's pretty cool.
What are some final words of advice for, you know, people
on the, well people on the, in the disability spectrum?
Or even just people who may not identify with
that? "Wow. This is gonna get me thinking." It's a little loaded.
Just,
just
release yourself from being bound by
certain conditions or
things that hold you back. Don't let anything or anyone hold you back.
That is my word of advice to folks. Do not let anything or
anyone hold you back because,
you know, when you, when you follow your own lead
and stand your ground, you can, you can just
like, you can have a lot of
awesome things arise without you expecting
it. And that's the whole meaning behind life in the first place.
Well, Ash.
Faith, thank you so much for sharing your story with
New York Public Library Oral History
Visible Lives is an oral history project in The New York Public Library. My name is Monica Diaz, and
I'm just very thankful that you shared your story.
Thank you for letting me share it.
(laughing)
When I got out of the hospital, libraries were my
sanctuary. Both local libraries and
Manhattan libraries. I'm in Queens, so
unfortunately, there's no NYPL in the hood. But, like,
but you know, both the Queen's library and New York
Public Library were
amazing resources to expand my consciousness
away from being bound by this horrible
damage that some doctors
felt that I was nothing
more than at the time. And I'm telling you
guys
for anyone recovering with any disability, Go to the
library. And there's visual
disabilities, there's audiobooks out there. My buddy
Ashok Rajamani just did an audio-
recording for his book, The Day My Brain Exploded. Everyone should check it out because it's an
amazing memoir about surviving
your brain exploding and
that's more TBI-related. Yeah but I'm telling you don't
I'm just a firm believer in not
letting a disability
bind you. And definitely
use that disability as an anchor to co-exist.
That's good advice. The library is also my sanctuary.
The library's also my sanctuary. "Cool." I think, it's
underutilized sometimes. "Totally. Yeah."
I'm actually, I was just talking to my
potential career paths in the future for
being a librarian. "Wow. Your mother's interested. Are you?"
Because I've loved libraries since the first
memories in life is learning how to read and loving it.
Yeah, and I was always in libraries when I was a kid
like, after everything is said and done and written, to just, like,
go for library studies of some kind.
At the Anti-Violence Project, when I was volunteering there more actively, I
was rearranging their library and, like, developing a system
for it. "Nice. Nice." So, cool.
Well, your story will be shared with, you know, within the
public library archives. It will be available to the public eye. I
am certain that everyone will be as awed as me by listening to your
story.
So thank you so much. "Thank you." For sharing, again.
Honor the
process.
That's my ultimate advice to everyone.
Honoring the process is a
motto that's helped me get to where I am
You did fine. "Thanks."